i should say we've also spent quite a
lot of time with the hobbit epidemiology
team
doing antibody studies tesla makes the
vaccine machines for cure vac gates says
something about me not knowing what it's
doing it's like paid knucklehead we
actually make the vaccine machines for
cureback that company you're invested in
seems like you have a lot of passion
around this topic like that you feel
this has been blown and that there are
better ways to do it which is
what you do in your other parts of your
life correct whether it's tesla or
spacex the rockets aren't aren't being
reused the cars aren't electric the way
we address viruses is irrational
it's very irrational
what's up people i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report direct message today
is may 11th 2022
and although we are live streaming on
youtube and rumble right now i somehow
am enroute
to california my former state because
tonight i'm at the brea improv with
dennis prager it's already sold out a
couple tickets left for oxnard tomorrow
with larry elder then san jose with
douglas murray phoenix with charlie kirk
and blake masters denver with brian
calland june 2nd orlando the big one the
big finish with governor ron desantis
it's all happening so we will not have
live in studio shows for a little bit
while i'm out on the road but if you
want to play along and do some live
chats and live video streaming and some
bonus stuff you can join us at
reubenport.locals.com
so we are doing a pre-taped uh q a today
nothing off limits as always and the
cold open that we did right there was
elon musk taking it to bill gates elon
musk basically the guy who now is the
ceo and owner of twitter who is saving
us from the endless stupidity of the
machine versus bill gates another
billionaire who seemingly is the agent
of the machine
so we're going to start today
with a little video this is bill gates
just a couple days ago
basically saying everything about kovid
that the rest of us have been saying for
two years
it wasn't until early february when i
was in a meeting
that experts at the foundation said
there's no way you know this
there's been too much
uh
travel without diagnosis uh for us to
contain this
and then at that point we didn't really
understand the fatality rate you know we
didn't understand that it's a fairly low
fatality rate and that it's a disease
mainly of the elderly kind of like
fluids although a bit different than
that so that was pretty scary period
right uh where the world
didn't go on alert
including the united states
nearly as fast as it needed to
and that freaking guy now first off he
is the founder of microsoft he created
windows remember windows you'd have
paint on there and maybe a spreadsheet
or microsoft word or something and that
is just fine and it was on everybody's
personal computer for a long time and i
give credit where credit is due you did
something good 30 years ago man it was
revolutionary at the time the government
hated you for it because they said you
became a monopoly that was a big case
microsoft uh they wanted to break up
microsoft et cetera et cetera but what
does he have to do with our public
policy at this point first off the guy
doesn't look good i'm going to jump
ahead a little bit here's a funny little
meme that
elon musk put up of uh bill gates right
there he looks like the pregnant man
emoji i mean that is a lot of soy right
there
so we've got elon musk a billionaire
who's fighting for free speech and then
you've got bill gates a guy who's in it
with the world economic forum and all of
those organizations that locked down our
economies destroyed the known world all
of that stuff and what he's saying is uh
yet now we know that it was low fatality
and that it was uh it was affecting the
elderly we knew that right from the
beginning i am not a scientist okay nor
am i a biologist but i knew that very
early on you just had to read the basic
studies of that and i would welcome any
of you to go back to my videos from
literally two years ago when i was
talking about a 99.97
something
rate of recovery and that it was only
really affecting people age 80 and over
and although we should
obviously take care of our elderly and
everything else that all of these
lockdowns that none of it worked none of
it made any sense but the reason i
wanted to show you this video today to
kick off the q a was that i think it
brings up something that we must not
forget
which is that these people these are
unelected people bill gates is not in
charge of anything except his many many
houses and all the people that work for
him and that's just fine uh but bill
gates
why is he involved in any of this what
does what does he do
other than create computer programs and
he hasn't done that in quite some time
why is he thought of as someone we
should be listening to related to all
this and i would venture to say i don't
know it for a fact but i'm guessing he
made a lot of money over the last two
years do you think he possibly made a
lot of money and there's also all those
videos where he's like and the next
one's coming
[Laughter]
i don't like bill gates very much let's
put him right under laurie lightfoot in
the who dave rubin done like list all
right we got a whole bunch of questions
from the reuben report locals community
and here we go
remy says what's the rule on hugs can i
take the time for my husband's hug and
use my use it myself to get extra time
only five days until i get to meet you
in san jose although i feel like i
already know you locals is truly the
best platform ever thank you and the
staff for creating it well i'm thrilled
with what's going on with locals and you
know i think there's a question coming
up in a few minutes about uh 2000 mules
on the launch on locals we're really
changing the game there as for the
specific question to the hug yes
someone else you know i'm i'm for the
one second hug during the q a or during
the the vip meet and greet uh people can
give me a one second hug cannot do the
two second lock but if someone if you're
with someone in this case your husband
and he's willing to forgo
his one second hug so that we can get
you to a two second hug uh that would be
just fine what i will not allow i cannot
allow it a lot of people have tried is
if you have a group of people and you're
with six people five other people all
give up their hug so that you can get a
six second it's just too weird you know
what i mean it's just i don't know the
people i know i don't hug for that long
so we can't do it sorry but the
two-second hug it will be allowed flint
says do you think conservatives should
use the intolerance of the left to fight
the culture war for example karl marx
was anti-semitic and racist in his
writing the left uses these tactics
unfairly against conservatives but
conservatives seem to not be willing to
stoop to their level well first off what
you just said is a hundred percent true
uh i would recommend anyone do a little
googling on the writings of karl marx
and he used the n-word quite often and a
lot of anti-semitic stuff too um but he
is the hero of the left of the purported
tolerant you know decent diverse lefty
blah blah should we stoop to their level
no
we shouldn't stoop to their level and
look we can all fall in that trap
sometimes and sometimes i say silly
things on this show usually in a joking
manner and we can all mock them to the
nth degree to the edge of the universe
and all that stuff but i think that
really the key is just be a little bit
better than them just be a little
happier than them just be a little more
functioning than them that's how we'll
bring people over they're gonna
constantly see one side that burns on
outrage faux outrage and anger and then
there's gonna they're gonna see another
group of people and they're gonna go
well these people are sort of
interesting and they talk about other
stuff than politics and they seem kind
of happy and they're sort of fun
and i guess that's weird because they
kind of call themselves conservatives
and that doesn't sound like such a fun
word but they do seem like better people
and then and i think the proof is in the
pudding and over time that's how you win
people over you just be a little bit
better so i know the inclination is to
stoop to their level and i really get it
when it comes to something like twitter
right because it sort of brings out the
worst in us it's always easy to own
these people and everything else but no
i think being a little bit better is
probably the best way to do it tallway
says do you have another book project
planned or do you think being a new dad
might put a temporary halt to your
writing
so
well first off on the latter part yeah i
mean look the dad thing is going to
change everything i'm going to continue
doing the daily show here we're going to
everything that you know of me doing we
are going to continue for sure without
question i love doing this and when i'm
on the road as i'll be for the next 10
days or so i miss being in studio i mean
i really do so i know i'm doing the
right thing in life when you when you
miss your work you know you're doing
something good um
but i but obviously some things are
going to change i i think i probably
will write another book or i'm willing
to say 100 that i will write another
book i don't know yet i want to see
look the first book was about the
principles i believe in the second book
was about how to thrive in a world that
feels very uneven as our world does
right now i think the third book i need
to wait a little bit see what happens in
the midterms like which direction really
is america gonna kind of choose and then
maybe i can write something that will
help get us to 24. i think that would
sort of be the idea um but i also have a
couple things that are not necessarily
as political and i do have this sci-fi
book that i kind of want to do
this sci-fi story that i've sort of
fleshed out as a short story already and
i'd have to i've never written a fiction
book so i'd really have to think about
it in a different way
but we shall see but yes everything is
about to change with these two children
on the way uh richard says dave who's
your favorite and least favorite
president and for what reasons well
biden by far is my least favorite right
i mean this guy's been an absolute
disaster i don't think he's in charge he
has old person's disease everyone he's
around is a chronic liar dr jill biden
is not taking good care of him this
administration has been a fiasco they
ushered him in under the idea that he
wasn't going to be a progressive nut bag
he is he poops in his pants etc etc it's
a lot so i don't like the guy
um my favorite president i mean i don't
know is it gonna sound cliche but in
retrospect trump was pretty freaking
good right it was all good except for
the riots that the left unleashed we had
a great economy we had world peace we
didn't have these crazy wards everything
was going well it really was then we
suddenly get covered out of nowhere and
we get riots out of nowhere i don't know
maybe that's why bill gates is smiling
taylor says with the new data now the
walgreens index showing little to no
benefit of the vaccine how are companies
and institutions able to continue to
require them and still with no mention
of natural immunity so it's a little
unclear to me exactly what companies are
requiring what at this point i don't
think are there any requirements by
private companies i mean i guess a
private company could still make some
private requirements to their employees
it's a little unclear but i would say
generally speaking
i never felt that i had the right to
inject any of my employees with anything
and i still stand by that and
that if you work at a place that wants
to inject you with things you should
look at getting another job i will also
mention that at the west nyack show
which is the last show i did on the
first leg of the tour with with megyn
kelly west niacc new york um when i was
doing some messing around with the crowd
there were a lot of nurses there and
there were several nurses that got fired
for not getting vac there were a couple
nurses there who ended up getting vacs
and they felt that they had to keep
their jobs and man what a horrific
choice what a horrific choice these
private companies forced their people
into the government forced government
employees into
really just evil it was just evil and in
retrospect think how evil i mean that
that that video of conor will throw it
in that video of uh in venice beach when
they were saying you know running over
with the bulldozer the skate park like
the chasing down
people on you know that were surfing
like the crazy things that they did in
the name of keeping you safe and man
it's like we should have been kept safe
from them not from this disease
you know
says what is david david's favorite meal
to cook
well i've said many times my favorite
meal for him to cook is his cast iron
chicken parm which you can see the
recipe at davidscookbook.com
or david's cookbook on instagram
and he is working on an actual physical
cookbook what's his favorite meal to
cook he loves
spice he loves all kinds of different
spices so he loves loves loves cooking
indian that's probably his personal
favorite to cook obviously i'm big on
the smoker these days so this past
weekend i mean we smoked a leg of lamb
that was massive then we smoked an 11
pound brisket we've had a lot of people
visiting us so it's been a lot of meat i
i can't i just smell like meat
constantly so if we do we have
smell-o-vision yet on the computer there
we don't we don't we're working on it um
because soon enough you'll be able to
smell me through the screen isn't that
exciting that's what we're working on
over here uh nathan says hi dave i hope
you all enjoyed the chick-fil-a oh i
know who this is it was great to meet
you and i was really entertained by your
wit enthusiasm and sense of humor what
was your personal your favorite personal
take of the atlanta show and your visit
here to the peach state so this is a
nice guy who i met who is a chick-fil-a
employee and he happens to be gay can
you believe it a gay guy selling fried
chicken to the masses and he gave me a
gift certificate to chick-fil-a we used
it uh in an airport i don't think it was
in atlanta we used it maybe in the
dallas airport if i'm not mistaken
what was my favorite part of the atlanta
show well i just love malice so michael
malus opened up the atlanta show and
he's just so witty and clever and he
does things where he'll like lay out a
joke and people don't realize it's a
joke so then there's this long pause
where people are like what what did he
say did he just say that and then and
then someone will start laughing in the
back and that kind of triggers somebody
else to start laughing and so there's
this almost weird backwards laugh which
is sort of exactly why i call him the
willy wonka of politics what else did i
do in atlanta you know it was it was
real quick that we were in and out but
we did actually go out after the show i
drank some tequila with some fans and it
was it was a good time
xavier says hey dave i saw your show in
atlanta and it was awesome disney has
run star wars into the ground but there
have been some small glimmers of hope in
the latest tv series they've been doing
mandalay mandalorian season two was
better boba fett had some cool ideas and
obi-wan is coming up in a few weeks is
there any chance they'll right this ship
all right well i think michael is not
going to be happy here when i give my
diagnosis of what's going on with star
wars look disney owns them i'm done i'm
just done i'm done they the last three
movies were absolutely horrible force
awakens was good the second one jedi was
so terrible that the third one was just
such a mess trying to clean it up
mandalorian's fine it's not great it's
not boba fett was barely in boba fett
they were like two episodes out of six
that boba fett wasn't in it they didn't
link it to anything you don't really
care about boba fett um
what else what was the other oh and now
obi-wan is coming out and it's like yeah
does it look kind of good it does but i
cancelled disney plus
and michael you can give me small recaps
in the morning of what's going on that's
it that's it i'm just not gonna do it so
i don't have hope i don't have hope that
a deeply corrupt
giant corporation that owns all of the
dreams that we're supposed to have
whether they're star wars or marvel or
pixar is gonna fix this thing the cool
thing of star wars and and you can watch
there's a documentary i don't even know
where you can find it anymore but
there's a two-hour three-hour
documentary on how george lucas created
star wars and it
what the cool thing is is not just this
the idea of the force and good and evil
and the father and son and all of these
things but when he was creating it it
was him going against the system
it really was and that that that spirit
was in those original movies and now
they're just corporate blathering drivel
so i i don't have much hope is that just
someone becoming old and just like you
got to give up on things maybe at some
level michael's nodding his head yes
um but i i look forward to finding well
as i said i have this new sci-fi idea
and i just watched dune for the third
time and i finally stayed awake and it
was pretty good it was pretty pretty
pretty good
joe says what do you enjoy the most
about live audiences um i mean i love
messing around with the crowd so for
those of you that have been in the
audiences you know i'm throwing t-shirts
out there and i've got people screaming
things and arguing with each other and i
sometimes bring people on stage and i
don't really plan too much so it's it's
a total free-for-all and i just love
being in a room with people where they
get to interact it would be as if if you
guys i was doing this in your living
room
and you were able to yell at me and i
was able to yell at you and we could ask
questions to each other and have people
in the audience debating things it's
just i'm just sort of managing chaos so
i just love and i just love seeing
people smile again man just that really
is it
marshall says there seems to be a new
movement around medical freedom what are
your thoughts about the medical about
medical freedom which is free of
coercion for all drugs and shots and
gives informed consent too so this is a
good one and we should do more on this
in general
now that we're entering the post-coveted
world although it's coming back before
the elections don't mark my words at
least in the blue states um
i'm basically for as much medical
freedom as possible and that you should
be able to do as many things especially
if you have a dire or degenerative
disease if you have alzheimer's if you
have hiv if you have these things that
traditional medicine is not really
working for or if you're really at the
end of the rope and there's nothing left
for you to try should you be able to try
all sorts of things to make sure that
you can stay alive yes do we need some
regulation probably could some of it be
private privatized to a degree probably
should we have more competition and less
regulation around drugs absolutely
um
you know there obviously is a risk there
is a risk too right you don't want every
snake oil salesman showing up and
telling people that they can cure cancer
if you inject this in your
into yourself just like you wouldn't
want snake oil salesmen say from giant
pharmaceutical companies called pfizer
to say oh we've just come up with this
vaccine and it's going to work until two
weeks later you realize it hasn't worked
and you've injected yourself and your
family with 10 of them
that's a problem
miss mama panda says what would you do
if jen saki showed up at your house with
a basket of cookies and a bottle of
tequila
well obviously i would take the cookies
and tequila and i would close the door
is that
that's the simplest question i've ever
got like you can't come in my house lady
i can't have i can't have those
heebie-jeebies i can't have those bad
vibes and that that that verbation of
lying lying and endless evil i can't
have that i would say i would take the
tequila i will take the cookies i'll say
i'll circle back to you
close the door
eagle says dave i heard that you are
stacking all of the income tax dollars
that you are not paying to california on
your kitchen table just so that you can
look at it from time to time and smile
is that true
that is a rumor however
i will say look
i did not leave california because of
taxes i did not love the taxes i did not
feel that they were doing good things
with my money
but that was not why i left i would have
stayed had the whole place not become a
dystopian [ __ ] but it did and it was
ruled by a psychopath gavin newsom
all that being said it is nice
knowing that we are saving a tremendous
amount of money to be in a place that i
want to live anyway like it's just great
and by the way prices for everything are
cheaper here too everything's crazy
expensive everything from food to
products everything in california at
least in la was bananas expensive so i'm
spending less on the day-to-day things
and we're saving a lot in taxes and that
allows us to do more things that we want
to do here and when we travel right with
my team we travel we travel the right
way
and we take care of everybody and and
it's all good it's all good when we go
out to team dinners who gets what they
want at team dinners huh
everybody everybody gets what they want
izzy says what were your thoughts on
2000 mules congrats to you you locals
and rumbles so first off on the locals
in rumble park dinesh d'souza creates
this movie
he launched it on locals we created a
new thing where you can subscribe
immediately and download the movie and
become a member of his community it is
one of the top 10 grossing movies of
this past weekend that we did on locals
which was just an idea that i came up
with a couple years ago and now we're
launching movies that i suspect it's
probably not going to win an oscar or be
nominated for an oscar because of
obviously the hollywood machinery but
i'm seriously thrilled that i helped
build locals it was my idea we then
merged with rumble and we're actually
building those alternate
uh roads of the internet so that's
awesome my thoughts on 2000 mules which
i did see i was at the premiere at
mar-a-lago a couple days ago
look he makes a very compelling case
they use all this geo-tagging to follow
these mules these people who take small
amounts of ballots and go to dropbox to
dropbox at odd times at night um when
repeatedly to these places over and over
and you can see these are not the people
that they're sending are not the best of
the best and they do it over and over
again and then they compile the amount
of ballots that these put in and they
that these people put in and they show
you this is the type of stuff that could
have flipped an election because you
don't need millions of vote votes to
flip an election you just need the right
amount of votes in the swing states
sometimes in just one specific city to
do things so he makes a very compelling
case i hope people will see it and then
think for themselves i don't know that
it's fully airtight obviously and dinesh
has his own political views as do i have
my own political views but i absolutely
think it's worth watching 100 and you
can see it by the way at 2 000
mules.locals.com
uh phillip says you have announced
locals has studio space in south florida
and daily wire has announced the same
thing is this a joint venture between
your two companies or a happy
coincidence i did not know that i was
not informed that daily wire is building
in miami but i think that's awesome and
i
fully support them and i think the more
the merrier and if that's competition i
love competition and that's fantastic
but yes locals has studios we're
building them out right now i'm going to
start doing some in person interviews
there but the real
idea of the local studios is that any
locals creator can show up whenever they
want we're going to have a big master
schedule and if people want to start
creating content there at our studios
we will help you create that content we
really are trying to build out not just
the pipes and the roads as i talked
about but
all of the things that you would need as
a content creator and especially after
the success of 2000 mules it's going
really well so
i am psyched uh angel says as you see
all of these leaks coming out of the
office of the supreme court it goes to
show that nothing is off limits to the
left do you think that the country is at
the point of civil war okay and this is
the last question so we saved the
heaviest for last clearly
first off
when people tell you that america is
racist when they tell you that they hate
this country when they tell you that it
is patriarchal and evil all of the stuff
that comes out of the modern left that
comes out of the squad that is pushed on
us by
almost the entire machinery of the
democrat party and the mainstream media
when they tell you that you should
believe them this is what they believe
why did i title the book don't burn this
country right it's like we have
something to preserve something that is
really good that was fought for and died
for before us that these people just
want to shred up and it's sort of like
that that godless hole right when
nietzsche said
god is dead and people thought oh that's
very exciting now we can do whatever we
want but really it was a warning it was
like well god is dead but if you kill
god that you might replace it with
something else and that thing might be
much worse well that's sort of what we
have right now we have this woke
ideology that is a secular ideology on
steroids these people think they can all
be gods and that the world should bow to
them as opposed to figuring out a way to
fit into the world that was created for
you by probably better people than you
so um
they want the thing to burn so i think
whoever leaked this thing and we have to
find out who did it needs to be totally
uh dealt with what in whatever legal
manner is available and then
if if we are to believe that any of this
machinery works
then we have to get back to letting that
machinery work and you cannot hire
people who will leak things and if it
was because someone hacked in then the
the people that were in charge of the
security have to be dealt with but and
if it was a justice themselves they need
to be impeached whatever it was it's
like
our institutions are shaking man like we
can all feel it the big thing doesn't
feel right and maybe that's okay that
the big federal government doesn't feel
right maybe it it shouldn't feel right
anymore and maybe that's okay and it's
easier for me to say that now that i
live in florida where the machinery of
this state is tight and it's humming and
it's greased and it's rolling right and
it's all good
um but maybe the machinery doesn't work
but they're telling us they want to
destroy the whole damn thing so your
question is are we are we at a civil war
i don't think so because i think people
are better than whatever the internet
has
say seemingly turned us all into i think
that when we all shut the devices and
we're all out there together that we are
a little bit better but i think you know
the way that the internet is it has it
has taken a young generation of people
and put them out on the streets to burn
things down that they only wish
in their wildest dreams they could have
been wise enough or brave enough or
smart enough to build so
uh i think we just have to keep
keep remembering what those founding
documents are keep living the best life
to get it back to that first question
keep living the best life that we can
and uh and get out there and laugh and
smile and be together with each other
and uh that is the winning case and
guess what that's exactly what i'm doing
and we got a graphic for it i'm back out
on tour tonight
in brea california and then oxnard san
jose phoenix denver and finally back
home june 2nd at plaza live here in
orlando with governor ron desantis and i
hope you will join us uh whatever few
tickets are remaining are available at
daverubin.com
events
you can always play along at
rubinreport.locals.com and this is my
last in studio show till i'm back from
this next little may portion of the tour
so we have a bunch of compilation stuff
and some other things going up and uh my
interview part two with uh yoram hazoni
on his new book all about conservatism
and can it can it sort of keep a wide
net or is it just not going to hold
which is a great question uh is up right
now and uh finally we've got a cold
close for you i leave you as i head out
on tour
with the president
well let's just say the elderly man
pretending to be the president of the
united states
most of the price increases we've seen
are were expected and and expected to be
temporary i don't know anybody including
larry summers who's a friend of mine
who's worried about inflation talk of
inflation
the overwhelming consensus is going to
pop up a little bit and then go back
down
no one's talking about
this great great thing it's highly
unlikely that it's going to be long-term
inflation that's going to get out of
hand there's nobody suggesting there's
unchecked inflation on the way
in this country do you take any
responsibility or policies i think our
policies help not hurt
think about what they say
the vast majority of the
of the uh
of the economist
think that this is going to be a real
tough problem to solve but it's not
because of
spending
we brought down the deficit the bottom
line is how much
does america owe
how much of the whole are we going
we're reducing that